Samsung Electronics provides many social benefits for its employees free of charge.
As the welfare state in South Korea is only slowly emerging,...
...Samsung Electronics stands out as an attractive and reliable employer...
...with its broad offering of free social services in Samsung Digital City.
These services include health care, child care, free food,...
...recreation and free public transportation.
In case you need to see a doctor during your stay in Samsung Digital City,...
...it is entirely free for Samsung employees.
The health care service is free at Samsung Digital City...
...with numerous medical facilities that offer everything from physicals and flu shots...
...to dental treatments and traditional acupuncture.
Samsung Digital City has 10 basketball courts, four badminton courts,...
...three soccer fields, two baseball diamonds,...
...a climbing wall and an Olympic-size swimming pool.
It also serves up to 72,000 meals with 92 different menus daily.
The cafeteria with more than 4,100 seats...
...sources its produce from Suwon's neighborhoods,...
...creating a strong link with farmers and producers.